[Music]
let's go to steve in grand junction
colorado what's up steve
hey john how's it going man good brother
hey you all do okay with the fires and
everything
well we're on the other side of the
state so we avoided it but that was uh
that was something else that was gnarly
man what a devastating mess that was
yeah we had the opposite problem we had
10 feet of snow
that same week in the mountains right
here next to us so
it's pretty bizarre that's so crazy
oh my gosh all right so what's up dude
how can i help ma'am
hey so um
i'm a retired cop um
i did it for seven years i say retired
because
it's a lifetime of experiences and
sorrow that you yeah you know
experienced in that amount of time
um
what do you do now
i'm self-employed now um my wife and i
own
three businesses because we're
serial entrepreneurs
and uh sick like that i guess you're not
making any money
what's that y'all making any money
we are yeah good
yeah
so it's a good fit um
so we've kind of hit a point here where
um things are starting to calm down a
little bit and i can think and i've been
able to hire some people so i'm not
having to do it all
and um
voices are coming huh
what's that are the voices coming
well it's more like
i'm a little concerned that there's some
things that maybe didn't deal with yeah
as a cop and
we've got four kids together
the oldest is 13 the youngest is six
and i'm just a little worried that
i don't know i guess i'm starting to
wake up to the fact that there's some
things like i don't know what i don't
know yeah and uh so that's i guess the
reason for my call is i was hoping you
could maybe
um give me a few pointers
i know um
you have a little bit of experience with
this i do yeah and um
yeah so well man thanks for your bravery
man thanks for your service thanks for
bravery and thanks for having the
courage just to to reach out yeah i grew
up in the home of a homicide detective
and a swat guy i grew up i was your kid
and i've also
run the streets with cops for several
years and
yes i caught my some of that stuff
leaking out onto my kids too and so yeah
absolutely
um
when you say i haven't dealt with some
stuff tell me about what you're thinking
about
well
i mean you know there's a lot of just
you just go from call to call and you
don't
really get to pause and deal with it
and you just wake up and do it again the
next day
yeah so
i want to stop right there so people who
don't know
most people have no idea as to how many
calls a police officer takes in a given
night
and you go from
noise complaint that
maybe someone's going to shoot somebody
to
dealing with a you know a 1016 like
there's a domestic somebody just beat up
their girlfriend and you got to get in
the middle of that and you may have to
arrest somebody you may not then you get
back in your car and then you go deal
with the 1087 there's a dead body here
somebody had a heart attack and they're
there but you got to make sure there's
no foul play and then you get in the car
and you go to like you just do that for
the whole shift
right yeah and then you go home yeah and
you
get up the next day and you get back in
the car and then you go straight to a
car wreck and then to another domestic
and then to another domestic and then to
that just never stops never ever never
stops and by the way you should go lift
too go work out and uh make sure you get
your dry cleaning done like it just
never quits right uh yeah
is there anything that's uh and excuse
this language is there anything that's
leaking out in your behavior or the way
you're treating your kids or your wife
that you think that man that doesn't
feel right
um
i think i just noticed things like you
know i can't like i'm having a harder
time just like sitting and playing with
my kids okay my patience is lower
um
you know you get pretty used to
squashing the motion yes
you go see one thing and then and for
whatever reason when i was doing it it
wasn't that bad i
i felt like i dealt with it i did
went to the gym i did a lot of mixed
martial arts um
i didn't drink couldn't
you know i knew i kind of knew what some
of the unhealthy behavior was and how to
deal with it but for whatever reason
now it's it's um more difficult i guess
you know you don't have the
the support of the guys that you work
with yep um
and um
who is your
who do you go hang out with and just
grab a drink with or who do you go hang
out with do you have guy buddies that
you guys spend time
yeah i've got friends they're more like
in the
they're outside of that realm yep they
don't really understand it yep
and those guys are still living it
working the night shift
it's uh it's nine o'clock here and i
just watched a friend of mine drive down
my road getting off a night shift yeah
yeah and is there a part of you that
misses it
i do i miss it and i didn't run the beat
like you did i miss it
yeah i missed the adrenaline there you
go i love the action
so um a traumatized brain and what uh
it's important to know a couple things
trauma is
um
trauma's acute and you know that right
you show up and somebody's you're with
somebody doing cpr on them as they
breathe their last breaths that's
traumatic right your body
has a trauma response there or you're in
the middle of a fist fight and you draw
your weapon and like that
that is and you're trying to protect
somebody
that's trauma
there's also
secondary trauma vicarious trauma
whatever you want to call it there's
just something about rolling up on scene
after scene after scene after scene that
we often don't know that trauma's
cumulative
it is a weight so think of it you may
have heard me say think of it like
you've got a backpack on and you're
carrying bricks and at some point
whether they're little pebbles or their
bricks that weight's the same and at
some point you got to do the hard work
of letting these things go
here's what i've seen with police
officers specifically over time
one is they have an adjusted bell curve
meaning there is a part of them that is
always looking for
what's about to happen
because police show up in situations
that nobody ever falls off drives off
that road right there except
that's your call and you it only happens
four times a year you get called all
four times so in your head has
identified that curve as a place to die
and you may not realize it that every
time you drive up your body begins to
tense up because it knows people die
right there and the rest of us would
just drive right by that thing we
wouldn't know same with
fist fights same with talking trash same
with a noise violation the last five
noise violations you showed up to ended
up in somebody getting arrested because
they were throwing
they were throwing punches or pulled out
a gun or whatever your body's detection
and i'm i've told this on the show i
think
i remember being a young kid and i
showed up to my house
with my dad and we had gone to baseball
practice in our little suburban
neighborhood
and
i left the back door open
and i'll never forget he pulled his gun
out and cleared the house
and i remember being a young child going
that's probably a little bit much you
know like i remember thinking yes that's
all right that's all yeah i've done that
before i know you haven't i know and
that's what happens yes and i still i i
do a lock check
two times sometimes three times at my
house i just make the rounds over and
over and over because i know people walk
by and they're not going to break into
your house but if the door's open they
may just come in right so i know that
and also my wife's like go to bed we
live in the woods like if they're out
here they're going to kill us anyway
haven't you seen any horror movies it's
going
mean and so
yeah um here's another thing i see a lot
is what i call overreacting
is
like something small happens and my body
has kind of lost the ability
to toggle down to an appropriate
response my all my responses become big
is that fair
does that happen yep okay and then the
third one is a loss of patience i can't
be still
and i can't listen for a long period of
time i just want to get on to the next
thing and i want to go solve this okay
cool i can't do legos one if i play baby
dolls one more time i'm gonna set this
all the dolls on fire it's that it it
just it feels like something's well
enough inside of you right is that fair
yeah so that's a that to me is a is at
least i'm not going to diagnose anything
that to me is a breadcrumb trail towards
a brain that is on fire
that's just still running and running
and running and the cool thing is
is what you have to do is
the cool thing is you can learn to a
feel safe in your body
b
live a life where your body is not
pumping adrenaline and cortisol through
it 24 7 365 and you have to understand
that's a drug that you're addicted to i
am too
i love it it feels good
and if i don't have it naturally if i
don't have it in my job if i'm not
running the streets with cops and doing
i will create it in other places i will
procrastinate up until the last possible
minute and get it all done because then
i get that rush or i will
kind of respond to a way a little bit
more and then i get that rush or you
know what i mean i'll create it in
stupid places that have no my wife's
like what are you doing that's not even
like this even a thing right so yeah
it's understanding hey i'm gonna go talk
to somebody have you ever done that
uh
i don't
it's it's i don't you know i don't talk
to a lot of people about it because i
don't think most people understand
and if you say something a little off
color or
really too honest about something
i've noticed it shocks people it does it
does um
so i really haven't because i i guess
maybe i've been a little lazy on it i
just i don't know who that would be
um
i mean i've gone to a therapist a couple
different times um
what'd you go i was
what's that why'd you go
uh first couple times were just
like marriage maintenance um
good for you we we got into a shooting
and they made us talk to a dude um
after that and that was totally useless
yeah
the last thing i'm gonna do is
talk to that guy of course
chief is you know they're like
psychologically evaluating you to see if
you're going to like go off the rails
right
like this is an honest
thing so
yeah um
not really no
well and you're i mean yeah you're not
going to say something that's going to
get you taken off the beat and so
everybody smiles and says i'm doing
great it's all good i'm sleeping well my
wife's great love my kids merry
christmas you can statue of liberty and
then they send you out yeah you can tell
it's just a check box for that's for
them that's right um i have i do have a
guy in my life that was
uh incredible but they had the the
police department had worked out a
system to where he was off out of the
system and so people could be honest
with him and it was it was it was pretty
remarkable um so here's here's a couple
things i want you to start doing
i want you to get
just go to the store dude buy a cheap
old one or you can buy a nice one i just
finally spent the money bought a nice
one for myself this year because i'm
gonna do some hard work this year i'm
doing the same thing you're doing except
you're do your your experience is gonna
be way more make more challenge because
i didn't run the beat for seven straight
years okay so i'm not trying to compare
my experience to you i know
that i've got to deal with some stuff
that i saw i got to deal with some stuff
that i was a part of i got to deal with
that
and
so what i'm going to start doing is
writing those stories down i actually
have got a story journal i put it right
by my bed i know the phrase story
journal makes most people roll their
eyes especially cops
freaking kidding me a story journal what
are we like in middle school again yes
and here's all i'm doing
a couple of nights ago i wrote in this
thing
you are not a bad father
and for some reason that popped into my
head
is my brain looking for negative things
you could have responded to that
differently you didn't do it bad let's
do it better next time that's me just
writing these things down and what i'm
doing is i'm teaching my body that we
are not going to carry this stuff i'm
going to set it down that when you hear
me say you set the bricks down that's
this that's the beginning stages there
okay and then there's going to be some
and i've heard you say that before and
i've um what do you what do you do with
this journal like you read it again do
you like it
well yeah occasionally i'll go back
through it and it's cool to see the
journey and it's cool to see oh gosh i'm
still hanging on to this story
still
what a i gotta go talk to somebody and
say i keep thinking that i'm a terrible
dad or some of it's i tell my wife dude
this has popped up five times in a row
like do you like me and she'll just say
yes i do like you john and then i could
say okay i'll write it down i asked my
wife she said she likes me there's
something kinetic about the writing
experience and about getting it outside
of your body
and uh but
so think less about the utility of it
that's a very police officer response
what are we going to do with it now
think more about it i'm just going to do
it i'm just going to get this thing done
and
um i'm going to be as gentle as i can
with the story because i know
there's all kinds of listeners here
i had an experience with a police
officer we had to clean up a scene
before a mom got home to see something
that no mother should ever ever see
yeah and we were by the time that
situation was over
i was laughing so hard i couldn't i
almost threw up
i somebody had turned into one thing to
another to another and i remember
thinking if somebody's videoing this i'm
going to get institutionalized and i
thought i talked to somebody about it
and they said no
that kind of dark humor like your brain
goes to places to protect you
and so there's also a camaraderie you
miss and that's what i don't like about
when whenever they post some police
transcripts some police officers are
garbage you know that um there's some
bad dudes out there that are idiots and
or morons and there's there's a number
of them
but also you can take things way out of
context and not understand what people
were doing at that time
right and you will have to process that
because there was a season when i
thought i was a terrible human and then
now i don't at all i know that's part of
it right i even talked to my dad about
it who did homicide for 20 years and
he's like no man you've got to protect
yourself and laughter is a great way to
protect your brain and protect your
heart protect your soul and if people
see you doing that they're gonna think
you're an evil awful you're gonna have
to process all of those things right the
jokes the things you saw the scenes you
had to clean up the moms you had to hug
all of those things over time make their
way out and not not every single story
but over time those things come and they
come and they come but it's about you
remembering them writing them down and
here's what you're doing with your brain
you are letting your brain know
at one time we were in a situation we
weren't safe
we're safe now
and your brain will go oh okay and it
will slowly start to go huh
relax relax the second thing you have to
have to have to do is have somebody to
talk to whether that's a counselor
whether that's a group of guys that you
meet with whether that's a group of
people who are still cops and you meet
with them and you you be the guy that
say all right how's everybody's marriage
doing
how's everybody taking care of
themselves what's the hardest thing you
all saw this week
what's the most annoying and you be the
guy that leads that group of guys into
talking because you can because you're
not in the system anymore
that would be a gift to you that would
be a gift to them and it will be a gift
to your entire community to have a group
of police officers who are well
and i know i'm i'm talking about
unicorns and rainbows right now but dude
if you set that up it could be powerful
because i've seen it i've been a part of
a police department where
they had that kind of discussion and it
was incredible it was magic man it was
really great yeah
yeah
but you're gonna have to get connected
and you're gonna have to start writing
stuff down
and then one man once you get down that
road when you get connected then you get
into all kind of the bodywork and
um i mean you can see the navy seals
guys who are doing meditation and yoga
and the guys who start running i mean
there's all kinds of ways to process
this trauma cold tubs
all kinds of ways to process the trauma
but it starts with connection and it
starts with um
writing stuff down
seeing where i'm at
it's deciding i'm gonna go play for 30
minutes with my kid i'm gonna do 30
minutes i can do 30 minutes and i'm
going to be all in i'm going to put my
phone away i'm going to have a watch and
i'm going to set it and i'm going to be
lasered in on these little dolls that
we're playing with or i'm going to go
kick a soccer ball for 30 minutes with
my kid i'm going to do it no matter what
if i get bored i'm going to lean into
the boredom if i get frustrated i'm
going to lean into the frustration
when i get frustrated i will have a
signal that i will pre-determine with my
wife and we will say
i'm frustrated i need to take a walk and
then i'll be back and she's gonna know
i'm gonna know and then i'm gonna come
back and i'm not gonna yell i'm not
gonna get angry i'm going to be calm i'm
going to be that that's practicing
leaning into a life that's not full of
adrenaline cortisol all the time
it's practice it's a practice
but i think every police officer should
have a good trauma counselor that they
talk to that just says hey i saw some
stuff
some people are affected in different
ways in other ways and
it's short-term long-term all that stuff
every everybody does trauma differently
but i want you know you're not alone i'm
proud of you god i'm proud of you man i
wish every police officer would take the
inventory on their lives that you're
taking on yours i'm grateful for you my
brother for your time and your service
and for caring about your family
so good
gentlemen talk about it with other
people write it down
talk about it and write it down